Film Courage: What are the best fights creative
collaborators should have? Joker movie cinematographer Lawrence Sher: Also a really
good question. They should always be
fighting about the movie right?
Never fight about the bull right?
Don't fight about win lunches and don't
fight about it like those are all
important things but they're not fights
that should be really happening you know
it's like don't fight like a Nick you
know
don't fight about bull. Just fight
about the creative things in the movie
right fight about challenge each other
to to not take the easy way right there
are a lot of this the nature of
filmmaking sometimes it's just the path
of least resistance the past path with
less friction people just often want to
check a box off so they can complete it
and move on to the next task
and I think I think it's always
important to to just be another voice in
the room that can challenge when when
maybe that that that we're taking the
route of Lisa of least resistance or
we're take we're taking the easy way out
instead of like continuing to push
ourselves to make the most uncompromised
version of the movie there are
compromises and everything so it's not
to say every single thing is is reason
to go to battle but I think you pick and
choose moments to just make sure that
like you know that that me and the
director and the actors and all that all
the departments are continuing to just
try to push ourselves to make the best
thing possible so as long as it's about
the movie I think the fights are
admirable and as long as you recognize
that it's a benevolent monarchy you know
or a benevolent dictatorship I should
say you really is that one person needs
to it's an essential part of the process
to be the final arbiter and that's the
director and that's pot that's super
necessary that director needs to at some
point draw the line and say this is the
way we're going and and discussion is
over and you move on so as long as you
don't keep fighting past that never hold
grudges have a short memory right if you
don't get your way move on
and and go go go into the next situation
as if nothing happened I think is is
always really really productive yeah I
think there's like this safety and it
comes back to trust where you know you
can get mad at someone and then the next
day you can see them and you can try to
reset that's right you hope that does he
hope that you don't get to a point where
you cross the line or something has
residual effect that's why as long as it
doesn't linger or lasts then you're
you're in a good place
yeah just like any relationship it's so
different yeah exactly it's a marriage
of sorts you know yeah and and also it's
a family it's the same way right and you
want to be able to fight with your
family in ways that you necessarily
can't fight with your co-workers or your
or your your your friends even in the
way that you know that the family is
always still going to be there right so
and and and unfortunately sometimes that
means you fight with their family worse
than you fight with your friends because
you don't create those boundaries but I
think it's very similar you know it's uh
you become super super close to the
people you work with and high stress
environments and all these other things
so you know it has all the fields as
they say you know in making a movie
you